con sus rascacielos bordeando el río
shanghai parece un templo del
capitalismo
la metrópolis es el centro financiero de
china y uno de sus motores económicos
sin embargo aquí fue donde nació el
partido comunista chino hace 100 años
en esta casa 12 idealistas se reunieron
en secreto para su primer congreso
hoy en día es un museo y para los 90
millones de miembros del partido es uno
de los tantos lugares sagrados de la
república popular china han venido de
los cuatro costados del país para
visitar los lugares reservando sus
tiquetes con varios días de anticipación
el edificio fue renovado y reabrió sus
puertas a principios de junio bajo la
supervisión del secretario del partido
en shanghái li qiang están exhibidas las
primeras traducciones al chino del
manifiesto del partido comunista de marx
y engels las fuerzas de seguridad nos
autorizan a hablar con los visitantes
una centena de metros más lejos dicen
maravillas sobre el partido nos llevaron
a un mundo nuevo para mí y para el país
el partido nos llevó hacia un camino más
próspero más rico el partido nos llevó
hacia un renacimiento en el mundo y le
permitió al pueblo chino se respetaba
alrededor del planeta
el partido representa a mi madre es mi
madre sin mi madre yo no estaría aquí y
sin el partido yo no estaría aquí
tampoco aprovechando esta maravillosa
vida
una versión oficial de los hechos que
beijing no ha dejado de promover en
anticipación al centenario del partido
la academia china de historia encabeza
estos esfuerzos fue creada por xi
jinping hace dos años para rebatir los
relatos históricos negativos
por ejemplo las salas de cine están
obligadas a proyectar y promover al
menos dos películas de propaganda cada
semana
y algunas nuevas producciones como 1921
se añaden al catálogo de obras
patrióticas un relato sobre la fundación
del partido que combina drama y acción
y favor
el otro curso nacional
chozas
para los que asistieron al pre estreno
la película cumplió sus objetivos
y realmente me siento orgullosa de vivir
en china hoy en día y siento mucha
gratitud por esos mártires
revolucionarios que se sacrificaron
mientras las autoridades imponen su
versión oficial también censuran
activamente las otras versiones una
nueva página web le permite a los
ciudadanos denunciar todo acto de
nihilismo histórico comentarios que
critiquen la ideología oa los dirigentes
del partido o que difamen a los héroes
nacionales
los historiadores que contactamos en
china continental y en hong kong se
negaron a hablar con nosotros o no
atendieron nuestras solicitudes
aun tu bondad investigador especializado
radicado en parís nos explica ese
concepto de nihilismo histórico
el objetivo es que las autoridades
políticas chinas puedan imponer sus
elementos del lenguaje quieren poder
imponer un relato nacional pero también
un relato sobre el partido piense en
china o en el extranjero entonces todo
lo que esté por fuera de esa línea todo
lo que esté por fuera de esos elementos
de lenguaje será considerado como
revisionismo histórico como mismo
histórico y por ende será sancionado en
cuanto tal
pero algunas voces todavía se hacen
escuchar que angus es un politólogo que
afirma haber sido despedido de la
prestigiosa universidad tsinghua a causa
de su trabajo sobre la revolución de los
paraguas en hong kong
con el paso de los años ha visto cambiar
la historia del partido en función de su
dirigente cuando el reformador den
xiaoping dirigía el país el caos y las
muertes causadas por la revolución
cultural fueron objeto de condenas
oficiales hoy en día esas críticas
desaparecieron
el cambio más importante en la nueva
edición de la historia oficial del
partido es que la historia está contada
de manera ni lista
sobre todo la parte sobre la revolución
cultural
sentencia que eso
que reduce unos diez años catastrófico
causado por la revolución a tan solo dos
páginas de jets bajos y jinping después
del levantamiento de los límites sobre
los mandatos presidenciales y el regreso
del culto a la personalidad
china también hace revisionismo
esa es la historia del partido que las
personas aprenden actualmente y está
centrada en el neo maoísmo de los
últimos nueve años que se llama el
pensamiento jinping sobre la gobernanza
es el principal relato de estas
festividades del centésimo aniversario
del partido y de esa manera se refuerza
la legitimidad del régimen actual así a
menudo la historia es definida como una
búsqueda de la verdad sobre el pasado
pero hoy en día para el partido es más
bien una manera de reforzar su poder